what was it like actually for you last
night uh at the premiere because you've
spent years you've spent a long time
working on this film and last night was
like the first time that a lot of people
saw it
um amazing i mean
i didn't sit through because the last
time i was in london finishing the film
for the last two like i watched the film
19 times in two weeks
so like i can't i can't really sit
through but um the reactions have been
really great and look you know
my favorite part of making movies is
like being on set
but the most important part is sharing
it with an audience so i'm and i'm so
like thrilled to finally be able to do
that because otherwise what's the point
you know um one of the things that
really struck me watching it last night
was the incredible sound design it is it
sounded amazing in that theater yeah can
you sort of talk a little bit about the
sound design of the movie because it's
really f and good thank you well it was
my first time working in atmos and i
have to say i love atmos because of the
not just because of the immersive
quality but the separation like the
sound design is incredibly dense the
sound design is intentionally
a bit too much
you know but because but i don't think
there's any way that i can communicate
the brutality
of the punishing landscapes without like
really amping up the the sound uh and
also i've never had so much music in a
film before and the score by uh robin
carolyn and sebastian gainsborough like
is like
we i think i think it's in a 215 movie
two hour and fifteen minute movie i
think there's two hours of composed
music uh and it's just driving us
forward but in order to hear like all
the different drums and the bone flutes
and the taggle harpa and like the
different kinds of nordic singing with
like the waves crashing and you know you
have like the atmos gives us a
separation to like hear all of it which
is really great if someone has actually
never seen uh either of your previous
movies and hasn't obviously seen the
northmen yet what's the first one you
want them watching i mean
it
depends if you're like
a snobby cinephile maybe try the
lighthouse but if you're just like a
person please see the northmen
sure um
one of the things that i would imagine
is getting people in the right headspace
before stepping on set um did you have
any of the cast or any of your crew uh
watch or read anything prior to actually
stepping on set that first day uh i mean
i don't know how many
cast members did did this but i
supplied them with a massive syllabus of
sagas and historical
art articles i mean tons and tons and
tons and tons of books i mean there's no
way they would have finished the amount
of stuff that i gave them but they had
the opportunity to to dig into all kinds
of things but i know i know alex
particularly was drawn to neil price's
book the children of ash and al neil
price being like this tremendous viking
archaeologist who was an advisor on the
film
there are so many impressive shots in
this movie but i would love to actually
spend a little bit of time talking about
the invasion of the village the 92nd i
believe it's 90 seconds or so um can you
sort of talk about or take us through
filming that sequence because it's um
it's kind of good
you know thank you well you know i mean
in some ways it's like choreographing a
a musical but it requires a lot more
blood uh but i th but but it is
it's um
what can i what can i say i mean you're
you're you're you you know you start
with the main action
like which is everything that amleth is
gonna do and then you just keep having
to go layer layer layer layer layer of
of all the extras all the stunt guys all
the horses the goats the chickens the
geese the sheep the children
you know and and you're you know we are
building a village from scratch to
accommodate where the camera is going to
be and to accommodate every beat in the
action
uh it's uh it's a whole lot of work i've
never
i've never planned something so
meticulously
in my life but there was no way to to
get around that you know around there's
room to get around that planning but the
the irony is is there were some simpler
scenes
uh
that were harder to shoot um because
they didn't get the same amount of tlc
you know um how many takes did you
actually end up doing of that sequence
to get the one that you use in the film
um i don't i you know it's it i know
that the first it's two shot it's two
shots in in the movie the the first
uh when we you know when the the
berserkers tear their skins off and
stuff i think that was like 28 takes did
you end up using the 28th take of course
right so you were basically waiting to
get a the exact thing you were looking
for yeah i mean
with the way we were shooting this film
single camera with these long takes it
was
i mean we're always using the last or
second to last take i mean i don't think
i don't with with those long winders
it's always the last or second to last
you are known for being as authentic as
possible um what was
the thing or things while making this
that you were a little bit frustrated
because there wasn't enough data or
historical evidence to sort of know
exactly what the right answer was so the
sort of uh
academic consensus has been that vikings
did not wear special clothing for
ritual purposes
but
it also
seems
you know it's the critical cons the
academic consensus is that also like
they're like you know spraying blood all
over the place all over themselves so
i'm asked neil i said well like so is
everyone just like
walking around covered in blood like all
the time like or or surely they must
have like special stuff they're wearing
and he said you know i've never
considered it like that because i've
never had to consider it like that you
know and that's something that
filmmaking can bring up so so we
designed special uh garments that we
call bloat cloaks uh for the for the
ritual purposes which is which it was an
invention but it was based on a whole
lot of
of research and suggestion and
uh and and there is a need for it
sure um
i'm obsessed with the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
um was it i i believe you had a longer
cut can you sort of talk about um the
challenges you ran into in the editing
room in terms of getting it to the shape
where you wanted it to be um basically
look i mean when before i gave this
script
to the studio i knew that it was going
to be so big that i was not going to
have final cut you know i knew that was
going to happen and it was a risk that i
was willing to take and the studio was
really great in like pushing this movie
forward and like and staying with it all
through kovid when a lot of movies died
but the editing process was incredibly
difficult um because uh you know i
promised them the most entertaining
robert eggers movie i could possibly
make but entertainment is not you know
uh my first instinct
and so the editing process was really
painful for me uh because of the studio
pressure but
like i needed that pressure to deliver
this movie and you know and and and and
this is like the director's cut there's
not going to be a longer version on the
blu-ray you know the the scenes that we
got rid of while some of them i'm very
proud of like will be supplemental
features for people to kind of like
check out some interesting things about
the goddess freya or whatever but
there's a reason why they're not in the
movie
um for fans of yours are there like will
you have 10 or 20 minutes of deleted
scenes yeah there's a there'll be yeah
there'll be quite a lot of deleted
scenes yeah are they finished or in like
a rough state some of them are finished
some of them are are some of them like
some of them i cut very early on but you
know uh of my own uh
being hard on myself but but some of
them are finished yeah it's interesting
because i speak to a lot of directors
and some directors refuse to show any
deleted scenes which i understand yeah
because because it can totally like
change it starts changing everything
that you're thinking about the film when
you uh when there's a scene where it
describes an aspect of a character that
you never knew
you know i can understand why you
wouldn't want to do that and you know
and maybe i shouldn't do it myself but
uh but we decided to if someone is
actually doesn't know anything about the
northmen um hasn't seen a trailer is
there like one or two things you want to
like tell someone about the movie to
sort of or do you sort of you know what
i mean uh it's tough like me personally
like when i watch a trailer if i'm find
it the least bit interesting i turn it
off and like you know write down the
name of the movie you know i i don't i
don't want to see anything i don't want
to know anything i really want to be
surprised so it's so but but of course
so much of my job in the past several
months has been like trying to find a
way to orient and explain and like you
know guide people into like what this is
but i think you know
if i could say anything this is an epic
viking movie that is truly done in a way
that has never been done before um
and
it has to be experienced in
theaters i 100 agree with that statement
you've made two films about america's
past and now you've made one vikings
movie the ratio says you might make
another vikings movie or am i completely
off base
uh
[Music]
yeah it's funny that once i was now that
i've started doing american press like
the sequel question
oh i don't mean i don't actually mean a
sequel uh at all i mean just you know
you made two films in america's past are
you
i think i'm more like much more likely
to make uh which i would like to do a a
third uh a
new england folk horror film at some
point yeah i i would i think a lot of
people would be um let me use the term
enthusiastic okay oh you know um so one
of the things obviously is no matter how
much time and money you have you're
always going to get limits if you had if
you were able to have more money or more
time was there something or a few things
you wanted to include but couldn't
because of those restrictions well i
don't know it's funny because like
there's there's three ships in the
beginning of the
film that come that come in to the
viking city and i think you know
certainly with a lot of tv shows you can
have the expectation of like
50 ships um but i also feel like
you know
three great ships are better than like
50 like cg ships you know
sure um besides the uh
there are so many it looks like when i
was watching it so many challenging days
in the making of this movie um were
there any days where you were just like
how are we gonna finish this
you know what i mean yeah every day
it was a really it was i mean the the
the locations were you know impossible
and so was what jared my dp and i were
out to achieve and
so
yeah i mean
yeah um i really enjoyed uh some of the
surprising left turns the story takes um
uh
i didn't expect certain things um can
you talk a little bit about coming up
with the story and um how it possibly
changed in the writing process uh along
the way
well um
when i when i decided that i i might
want to make a viking movie with alex
skarsgard i came across
the story of amleth which inspired
shakespeare's hamlet and that was great
because this is a myth that everybody
knows so i can make this large-scale
epic movie
for broad audiences but i can explore
the ritual world and the mythological
world in a way that you may not
so
it's not so common in a film
this size um and uh you know so we kind
of went with that i think uh you know i
mean so many things shifted and changed
along the way i mean the first
draft that shown
sent me
uh like after we we had developed the
story together but then he went off and
did his own thing i mean it would have
cost like 350 million dollars
right
in the credits you thanked ari chris
columbus and alfonso quran and i'm just
curious why how did they get thank yous
uh they all
saw the film at some point and gave me
notes and support and uh
yeah were there any like um
uh any key notes that your film you know
friends and family gave you on the
editing process that really
how had you see the film in like a new
way to help you in the editing you know
yeah for i mean there's not there's not
there's not some like special golden
fish that i like that i can
point to but but you know that helped
the test screenings i know i hate the
test screening process and i hate even
the worst part about the test screening
process is that it's not enough
data to actually mean anything but
you still i still learn things from it
you know i still learned a lot of things
from it like again
i don't like it
but but you but it's helpful i'm about
to run out of time with you and i'm kind
of a fan uh i obviously have to ask you
are you when do you start filming a
certain other movie you know i just
like
i don't know
i don't know but i'll also mention that
because it's out there that harry styles
was not meant to be the
the vampire himself oh he was going to
play something else yeah yeah i'm just
going to say man
love the [ __ ] movie sorry for cursing
and i wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much